Charles slack what was the noble
obsession
well the noble obsession in the title of
the book is was Charles Goodyear's
obsessive quest to find a way to take
rubber which was a sort of a an
industrial curiosity an industrial
sideshow until he got ahold of it and to
turn it into a commodity which really
changed the world and he went on a quest
for about ten years to find the secret
and then to perfect it and he did it at
tremendous cost to himself and to his
family and that was his noble obsession
he was obsessed with rubber on the cover
of this book now you have two
photographs right one of these is
Charles Goodyear Charles Goodyear is the
fellow on the left and the and the
fellow on the right is Thomas Hancock
who was Thomas Hancock and Thomas
Hancock was Charles Goodyear's principal
competitor Charles Goodyear was an
American Thomas Hancock was an
Englishman and Thomas Hancock had been
known as the father of the rubber
industry the early rubber industry when
it first began appearing in large
quantities in the early 1800s in Europe
and America and he had come through with
he was a brilliant inventor and a very
good businessman and he had come through
with with some very important
discoveries and inventions on rubber
where he and Goodyear clashed Goodyear
on the other hand was was obscure a
poverty-stricken in and out of debtors
prison ridiculed by by virtually
everyone pitied by those who didn't
ridicule him and where their two worlds
came into collision was when Goodyear
had finally perfected the process and
sent over some small samples foolishly
because he hadn't taken a patent out yet
but Fenna sent some samples over to
England to try to attract British
investors he always needed money and
they got into the hands of Thomas
Hancock and Hancock decided to see if he
could reverse-engineer
these samples he was dumbfounded because
he had thought that rubbers great flaw
couldn't be solved and he saw that it
could and he was dumbfounded and he
spent the next year in his secret
laboratory reverse engineering
Goodyear's invention and actually beat
Goodyear to the British Patent Office
which was the most important at the time
I suppose the obvious question is what
year did Charles Goodyear start the
Goodyear Tire and Rubber Company well
that's it that's a good question and it
and it leads me to to the discussion of
what this book is not about and that is
it's not about a book about tires and
it's not a book about the Goodyear Tire
and Rubber Company for the simple reason
that Charles Goodyear died in 1860
before there was any need for an
inflatable tire and the Goodyear Tire
and Rubber Company was started by two
brothers in Akron Ohio in 1898 38 years
after Goodyear's death and because of
the name of the company there's a
there's a good deal of confusion on this
on this point my own mother that I was
writing a book about tires my own mother
well into my process would ask me how
the Firestone book is coming now when
you go to is it headquarters still in
Akron Ohio for a Goodyear could you have
Tire and Rubber is headquartered in
Akron have you been there I have I went
to Akron twice I did some research at
the company which has become sort of the
de-facto repository for a lot of
Goodyear memorabilia documents and so
forth the University of Akron archives
has a couple of cardboard boxes full of
Goodyear information and Goodyear
company as it relates to Charles
Goodyear information and then also
there's a place called the rubber
library which is in Akron and I spent a
good deal of time researching there how
did they get the name then how did how
did yeah well it was it was these two
brothers Frank Seiberling and and his
brother Charles and they Frank was the
was the the original founder and was
looking for a company to start and the
BF Goodrich company had already been
started in Akron and I think that
Goodyear
serve the dual purpose it had sort of a
nice association in the word with
Goodrich it sounded similar and also it
was a way to pay homage to Goodyear and
to also associate itself with the birth
of the industry now in the back of your
book were under the liner notes about
you Charles Locke is the author of blue
fairways yes well that was a book on a
completely different subject I had taken
up golf while I was a reporter at the
Richmond times-dispatch and I had this
idea coming home from a round of golf
one day wouldn't it be nice to to see
America by just going one golf course to
the next because when you play golf you
get five hours with perfect strangers
which is something that you don't get in
very many other activities environments
so I had this idea and I I started on
Route one in northern Maine Fort Kent
Maine and I worked my way down one golf
course at a time to Key West Florida and
I played excuse me in the in the potato
fields of northern Maine and I played in
the Bronx and I played in the Okefenokee
Swamp and down the coast of Florida and
how long did it take you it took me over
a period of three months I didn't do it
all at once but I took a leave of
absence from my newspaper job which I
had at the time and as soup was a
six-month leave of absent the traveling
took about about three months of that
what year did you do it I did it in 1997
the summer of 1997 and the book was
published in 1999 and how well did the
book do well it did it did pretty well
it's it's went into paperback and it's a
it's still going in paperback in stores
and and it's got a nice reception what
would you say was one of the big lessons
you learned from that three months on
the road that I that I loved golf still
and wasn't that crazy about hotel rooms
but I learned a lot about America I
think the I had sort of expected Route
one to be an exercise in nostalgia and
sort of rundown motels and and it's been
superceded long sense
by Interstate 95 and what I found was
really in both the golf courses and in
the road itself signs all over of
America reinventing itself at every turn
and so it was really Stora sort of a
story about renewal and the future as
much as it was about about the past I
came across wonderful old old golf
courses that had been brought back to
life by concerted efforts of inner city
residents and things like that the noble
obsession book which one is this for you
this is my second where did you get the
idea can you remember the moment it says
I do it was in this it was in the summer
of 2000 and I was reading a book that my
parents gave me a long time ago which is
one of my favorite books Webster's
American biographies and it has these
wonderful sort of thumbnail sketches of
people and I was just reading through it
one day and came across Goodyear's name
and I assumed like I think most other
people that this was just I almost
didn't read it because I assumed that
this was just going to be sort of a
history of a guy who started the tire
company and died rich in Akron well I
read the entry and the more I read the
more fascinated I became there were
stories of there were mention of debtors
prisons which I didn't even know we had
debtors prisons in this country I
thought that was Dickensian England
Europe a European phenomenon and and and
found that he was not the man who
started the tire company but a starving
inventor from Connecticut and there were
just all these and then the the story of
of the the competition with Thomas
Hancock and and so forth came up and the
more I read the more fascinated I became
and then I took a trip out to to Akron
my first trip out and went to the rubber
library and started researching there
and I just became more and more
fascinated which to me is always a good
sign that this is something that I might
be able to make interesting to other
people in the middle of your book Daniel
Webster shows up isn't that great
Daniel Webster who was was an incredible
figure he was sort of like a movie star
in the way that people treated him and
people thought of him he gave three-hour
speeches that held people spellbind he'd
held just about every important national
office with the exception of the
presidency and he came in probably my
chief villain I see Horace I see Thomas
Hancock is sort of a tragic figure in a
way in the sense that he was a wonderful
inventor himself and he made this sort
of ethical choice not to give good year
credit and I see and it's sort of a fix
to his name this sort of sort of mark of
a bit of a cheat or a sneak when in fact
he was a wonderful inventor so I see him
as sort of a tragic figure there is an
out-and-out villain in the story and his
name was Horace day who not only got
rich off Charles Goodyear's invention
but made it his goal in life to rip off
Charles Goodyear however and wherever
and whenever he could
and finally Goodyear this was after the
discovery had been made and good.your
held the US patent even though he'd lost
out on the English patent and Horace day
had been infringing and infringing and
finally Goodyear's licensees in America
the the Goodyear Shoe Association got
together the funds to to sue Horace day
for patent infringement in a case that
became known as the great india-rubber
case of 1852 and they hired as their
attorney Daniel Webster who was then
Secretary of State to millard fillmore
and he was at nearing the end of his
career he was close to seventy years old
suffering from cirrhosis of the liver he
was had had lost a step or two to say
the least
he really didn't need the publicity to
be had from representing good year and
his licensees but he needed the money he
that was what he had in common with
Charles Goodyear for all of his August
positions that he'd held he was a
spendthrift and he needed the money and
they offered him what was then a
phenomenal sum of ten thousand dollars
plus another six thousand dollars if he
could win this case I come back to that
but go to Charles Goodyear for a moment
what were the years that he lived
Charles Goodyear was born in 8:00 in
1800 and he died in 1860
and where was he born he was born in New
Haven Connecticut when he was 5 years
old he moved to Naugatuck which is about
10 or 12 miles up the road due north the
the good years were actually founding
members of the New Haven colony his
ancestor Stephen Goodyear was one of the
wealthiest and principal founders of the
colony back in the early 1600s where do
you live I live in Trumbull Connecticut
which is about 20 minutes from New Haven
interestingly for me I probably didn't
plan it out as well as I could because
at the time I did all the research for
my book or most of the research I was
living in Virginia and so my research
included long trips to places that I now
live 20 minutes from what was his family
like when he was growing up well when he
was growing up his father a massa a mas
a Goodyear was a an inventor himself he
produced the the buttons borne by
American soldiers in the war of 1812 he
he was a tinkerer and a businessman and
and he had two principal qualities that
he passed on to his son and and one was
a vision for products that others didn't
see and being ahead of his time and the
other was a debilitating lack of
business sense a lack of how to be a
business man and so Goodyear at Charles
Goodyear inherited both of those
Goodyear was the oldest of six children
and when he was five they amass ahead
run a shipping company in New Haven I
actually found a notice in a New Haven
newspaper for for a shareholders meeting
at a massive Goodyear's house but that
failed and he moved the family up north
into the wilds of Connecticut to run a
mill did Charles Goodyear have education
Charles Goodyear had a I think for the
time a pretty good education you didn't
have a higher education but he he did
have
through through his teens and he was a
very sort of serious studious child did
a lot of reading particularly of the
Bible as we sit here right now I suspect
you could find rubber in our shoes and
our socks in our underwear
panel where else everywhere everywhere
what about in the early 1800s could you
know you couldn't rubber had been around
for centuries the South American natives
had been using it and it Europeans had
been aware of it since the late 15th
century and 16th century in the early
1800s it began making a strong
appearance into the United States and in
Europe and there was a great deal of
excitement because it was just at the
very dawning of the Industrial Age and
there was a great deal of excitement
there was no other substance like it it
was airtight it was waterproof it was
elastic you could stretch it out and it
would snap back to its original shape
you could compress it and it would
bounce back it had a seemingly unlimited
variety of uses which later proved to be
the case and in the 1830s it really took
off and people started investing I sort
of compared it to the Internet boom of
the nineties where it attracted all
sorts of investment from people who
weren't sure exactly how it was going to
make a profit but they didn't want to be
left out well rubber turned out to have
a very fatal flaw which is that when the
temperature gets very hot out
rubber becomes sticky this is raw rubber
that we're talking about becomes sticky
and then if the heat is intensified it
becomes gooey and then it actually melts
and starts to run and when the weather
gets very cold it starts to crack and so
sure enough in New England which has the
wild temperature swings that it does the
first really hot summer came along would
have been maybe like this summer and all
of these life preservers and raincoats
and so forth that the Roxbury India
Rubber Company and other companies had
had produced were being returned as
sticky gooey
blobs foul-smelling and they were
sitting back in the warehouses so for
all intents the rubber industry looked
like it was dead in the water by the way
you see the word India so often in the
title of these rubber companies where's
that coming from
that's from from the Indies which is the
the rubber the rubber plant is actually
rubber it comes from latex which is
produced by about 300 varieties of
plants around the world latex is the
sort of milky substance and you can find
it in for example dandelions if you snap
off a dandelion you see that sort of
milky ring that's that's latex one
interesting story is during the during
World War two when the Japanese
blockaded the the rubber plantations the
Soviets actually experimented with
cultivating vast fields of dandelions to
to supply them with rubber and Thomas
Edison at one point experimented with
cultivating goldenrod too to get his
rubber but the best rubber comes from
from a plant the haveá-- tree which
comes from which is native to Brazil I
wrote down a bunch of words that in
reading about the rubber when you get
past the latex and you get to magnesia
and then you get to turpentine and lime
and nitric acid and nap naphtha urine Oh
local night what are tell us about how
all those ingredients got into this well
rubber comes out as I say in this milky
latex form then it has to be and it's
it's called it's sort of it's compared
to milk frequently and and not just
because of its texture and its
appearance but also because it spoils
quickly so what happens what happened in
in good years time was was in Brazil or
wherever the rubber was coming from the
latex the latex would be smoked the
water removed and what you would have is
these layered what were called biscuits
of rubber and they would be very
inconsistent and they would have soot
and they would have ash and whatever
else was floating around the air
in the jungle and when you had this sort
of knobby lump of rubber you had to find
a way to make it usable to break it down
and one of the the substances that can
be used to break it down is turpentine
and so Goodyear's first experiments like
all the early rubber experimenters were
to chop up and tear up rubber into small
pieces roll it out mix it with
turpentine until it became this sort of
semi liquid substance that can then be
spread on cloth shaped into various
shapes and so forth how did he first get
interested in it and where did he live
Goodyear was living in Philadelphia he
had gone to Philadelphia as a teenager
and worked as an apprentice to a
hardware hardware store and then he had
gone back to he'd had physical breakdown
he was in terrible physical health his
entire life and he'd gone back to
Naugatuck and then shortly after he was
married he went to back to Philadelphia
in 1826 to start what was the first
american hardware store that was devoted
solely to domestically produced goods
they produced his father produced hay
and manure forks which were made of
steel and lighter than the other kinds
and they and he'd be manufactured other
goods and and they started this hardware
store well about 1830 there was a
financial panic and the the hardware
store basically collapsed could your
head his first stint in debtors prison
and it was about 1834 when when when
Goodyear came across rubber for the
first significant time and he was in a
in the offices the New York offices of
the Roxbury in the India Rubber Company
which had been the first and the biggest
American Rubber Company and UK and and
he came across a life preserver and he
decided that he could make a better
valve for the life preserver and so he
went back home and perfected this valve
he wasn't really thinking about rubber
at that time and then he came back with
the valve and
tried to sell it to the agent and the
agent said well this is a great valve
but I've got something to show you when
he took him around to the warehouse
where there were just these ranked foul
blobs of goo which had been life
preservers and caps and so forth that
had been returned because of the heat
and the way Goodyear told it was this
agent said if somebody wants to make his
mark on the world he should find a way
to prevent this from happening and that
a light went off or a bell rang for
Goodyear or something and that became
his obsession for the rest of his life
he would have been 34 years old and
918th right how many times did he marry
he married twice his first wife was
Clarissa and she died in the early 1850s
and then he married he was living in
England at the time and then he married
a 20 year old English woman Fanny
Wardell when he was fifteen three or
four yes and how many children in the
air he had a total of 12 he had nine
with his first wife and three with his
second and of those seven died of war he
did of just various ailments they they
there aren't a great deal of of records
about what exactly they died of but but
they were the family was
poverty-stricken for a great deal of
time they were undernourished and they
the young children several of them
succumbed what did she die Oh Clarissa
it's not known unfortunately what what
she died of and he lived to be 60 years
old yes you say at the end of his life
is 191 thousand dollars in debt yes
well close to $200,000 in debt and
that's the Year night that's that's
right
Goodyear lived much of his life for most
of his life in poverty or in financial
straits I should say poverty is probably
the wrong term to use for the later
latter part of his life in the during
his obsessive quest to find the the the
the vulcanization process which he which
he discovered which changed rubber and
changed the world by the way before you
going what does that mean
okay look balkanization is the term it
was actually the term was devised by a
friend
of Thomas Hancock's named for the Roman
god of fire Vulcan but oxen engraved in
England
riotous time and but vulcanization is
the process which by which rubber is
transformed so that is no longer
susceptible to heat or cold and this was
good years great discovery
I can I can explain that I come back to
the other subject its rubber has this
quality as I say of being pliant and
elastic and the chemical properties of
rubber really weren't known too well
into the 20th century so so everything
was trial and error and and even after
the process nobody Goodyear nor anybody
else really knew exactly what he
discovered why but rubber it has the the
molecular makeup of its c5h age it's
five carbons eight hydrogen's and that's
not very notable it's not too dramatic
but what was discovered in the 20th
century was that rubber is actually not
just that one unit of c5h ache but it's
20,000 of those strung together in what
in a macro molecule so you have these
long snakes they're still very small
compared to what we can see but but
they're gigantic compared to most other
molecules and they're not connected
rubber molecules are not connected to
one another at a molecular level they
are if you can imagine thousands
millions of twisted snakes twisted
around each other into a ball and so
when you pull rubber those snakes they
the chains sort of stretch out you let
go when they snap back to their original
state beep Rhett you compress it the
same thing happens they snap back so
that's the wonderful property of rubber
but since they're not connected at a at
a molecular level when you add heat the
those long snakes those long chains
relax and they begin to slip away from
each other and so that's where you get
the stickiness and the the goo and and
so forth so back in those years if you
said come with me I want to take you to
the warehouse and show you a rubber and
you walked in there what would you see
what did it look like well was it a
block was it a sheet was it black was it
oh well it would all depend on what
state it was in if it was in if if you
you might have a hunk of I have a hunk
of raw rubber at home it's just sort of
a square piece I mean that it would come
from from South America in these these
lumpy biscuits and then it would be
chopped up and so forth and sometimes it
was maybe when it was mixed with its
turbo time sometimes it would be spread
on cloth so you'd have rubber fabric
other times it would be made into
products that were solid rubber so if
you go back to the death thing before we
get to the vulcanization and by the way
what year I need to I need to explain
what exactly and I'll do it quickly but
what vulcanization did was when Goodyear
finally after experimenting with many of
the the chemicals that you that you
mentioned which may have helped kill him
he happened upon sulfur which what
sulfur does sulfur with heat it connects
those individual rubber no molecules
those long chains to one another so it's
called cross-linking so what you have is
a substance that still is pliable you
can still stretch it and snaps back and
compress it in snaps and it's still
waterproof and airtight and all those
wonderful things but since the molecules
are now connected to each other they're
much stronger so under heat it doesn't
run so that was great that was the
vulcanization that was his great
breakthrough but the $200,000 in debt in
1860 is what that worked today a lot
millions yes he said he was in poverty
most of his life early on during his
quest
that was that was I wouldn't think think
his fault because it was just he just
didn't have the money later he bears a
lot of responsibility for that he was a
miserable businessman he was careless
with money he didn't have much of a
concept of money and so no matter how
much money he made he kept spending it
he didn't live he wasn't a spendthrift
in the sense of buying himself
huge mansions and so forth but
everything that he earned went back into
more experiments and after he'd come up
with the great breakthrough and other
people were making money on his licenses
by cranking out widgets and so forth
Goodyear was off trying to invent trying
to create rubber ship sales and these
rubber globes that that he would fill
with gas and they'd float to the the
ceiling and he just had this sort of
romantic conception of rubber in life
and he didn't have much of a business
sense how many times did he go to
debtors prison I'm not sure the exact
number but he he had his first time in
Philadelphia and his last time was more
than 20 years later in England so hey I
get the impression those many many many
times yes many of how long would you go
to debtors prison and what was it well
debtors prison was really sort of one of
the in my opinion one of the more
shameful things that from from the early
from the 19th century
for a country that sort of person
professing itself to be dedicated to
liberty it was this it was this
horrendous institution where you could
be locked up essentially for very
trifling sums you you became sort of the
property of your creditor who decided
when you were going to be who decided to
have you arrested if you couldn't repay
in Philadelphia where Goodyear was first
imprisoned creditors had to pay a 20
cent a day bread fee for for a couple of
loaves of bread and a blanket for or a
loaf and a couple of blankets to keep
you alive and essentially could keep you
there indefinitely they I think most
terms were a period of days maybe 20
days and so for but some were some were
far longer you say that he lived in
Connecticut Pennsylvania New York
Massachusetts England France and
Washington DC why was he here in this
town well he came back he lived there at
the very end of his life it was the last
place he lived and he'd come back to the
United States he'd been living in
Europe in France and England and he came
back in the late 1850s to fight a patent
extension which case to try to extend
his patent and claim that he hadn't made
enough money off off rubber and to keep
this keep his patent alive for another
ten years and he won this case and then
he came back to the United States full
time he was living in New York and and
he moved to Washington and it's not
clear exactly why why he moved to
Washington but I think that he was down
there for that that case and and and
liked it how long did he live in england
or in france he lived in england he was
sort of off and on it's very difficult
he moved around so much but he moved to
England in the early 1850s and he became
a major part of the Exposition of 1851
he had a wonderful the London exhibition
and and had a wonderful exhibit there
which got a lot of attention it was
really his medium because it wasn't
something where he had to to sell
products and and show how to make money
off rubber it was it was celebrating the
aesthetic wonders of the world and he
was able to produce this exhibit that
had paintings on slabs of hard rubber
and and armoires and metals and so forth
and it really was apparently a
breathtaking exhibit and he was over
there for for a number of years and he
went there was an exhibition in France
later which he also participated in and
he lived there for a couple of years if
you were gonna make the most positive
statement you could about what he
accomplished what would you say Charles
Goodyear did Charles Goodyear through
his almost superhuman perseverance came
up with a with an invention that changed
the world that took a substance which
would only have a sideshow type of
benefit to people and turned it into
made it capable of becoming a substance
that is a part of everything that we do
to this day
they people think mainly of course of
the automobile the tires which which
vulcanization made possible but rubber
also since it doesn't conduct
electricity it's a poor conductor of
electricity it became essential as an
insulation for the electrical industry
for telephones plumbing aviation it's an
essential component so that's what he
gave the world and what year did he do
the actual inventing it he made the
discovery by accident he was living in
Woburn Massachusetts or is Wilburn
Woburn is is about 10 miles north of
Boston and he was living there he'd been
in Roxbury Massachusetts which is in
part of Boston and had been working with
what the remnants of the Roxbury and
over India Rubber Company by that time
the rubber industry had shrunk down to a
very few hardy souls who still believed
in it this was in the early 1830s early
to mid 1830s and had a falling out with
the Roxbury into rubber company and
heard about a mill in Woburn
Massachusetts a few miles away and so he
moved to Woburn and began working with
Nathaniel Hayward who was a had been a
stable operator but had become enamored
of rubber and actually first gave
Goodyear the idea to use sulfur in
experiments and Goodyear worked in in
Woburn for several for several years and
came up by accident with the discovery
and in in 1839 and it's not clear
we have good years own account of it but
it's his his memoirs are written in this
sort of third-person elliptical vague
hard to pin down way but it seems that
that he had been mixing sulfur with
rubber and dropped some on a stove and
then came back later and was astonished
to find that the rubber hadn't melted
but it had toughened and that was his
great that was he knew that that was a
great discovery by that time everybody
was fed up with the rubber industry so
industry so he couldn't convince people
that he'd come up with this important
discovery and then you
so had a very difficult time reproducing
it so that was another one of the most
poignant aspects of the Goodyear story
is that when he had this Eureka moment
it wasn't like his life turned for the
better if anything he sank deeper into
poverty while he and and despair and he
became consumed with the fear that he
would die before the world recognized
this discovery he made he was sick all
the time of what he was sick from the
time he was a teenager and perhaps
before he had gone at the age of 17 to
work as an apprentice for a for hardware
company in Philadelphia and had to leave
because he had a physical breakdown he
it was sort of his ailments came under
the the general umbrella term of
dyspepsia he had various gastric
problems and these plagued him
throughout his life he also worked with
a number of very harsh substances
including nitric acid and lead and and
he there was no there were no safety
codes in those days he was mixing it
molding it with his hands and that
perhaps contributed he suffered from
gout he was kind of a physical wreck so
if you go back to 1839 he's in Woburn
yes it is his wife they've been married
for how long they were married in the in
the 1820s so I guess about 13 years and
how many children that they had at that
time they she had nine of his kids yes
so would have been would have been six
or seven so if you were able to see him
where he lived and what kind of debt he
was in at that point what would you see
and and where did he do his experiment
because yeah if you talk a lot about
doing experiment on his kitchen stove
yes he did experiments basically
wherever he could find heat because to
to you know once he once he knew that he
was an essential component he began to
look for for fire wherever he could find
it and he would when he the
was able to use this mill in Woburn he
would use that he built an oven there
but he was chronically behind on his
payments so so he was not always able to
use that he would go around to the local
blacksmiths and and cajole them he was a
he was an excellent beggar he had no
shame he was convinced of the holiness
of his mission and he had no shame about
sponging off his fellow residents of
Woburn or anywhere else for use of their
fire or for money and he would go around
to the blacksmith's and so forth at the
end of the day and say can I use your
fire before it dies out and and of
course some of them agreed that one of
the most wonderful aspects of his life
was the forbearance of the citizens of
Woburn mass who who put up with him he
was a stranger basically and put up with
him and showed him kindness and and
other residents showed kindness to his
family when they saw them digging half
grown potatoes out of the fields for
food who was Horace Cutler Horace Cutler
was a was a minor but very important
figure in the Goodyear story when
Goodyear had moved to on from Woburn to
Springfield Massachusetts and was was
working there on perfecting his his
process this was after his discovery of
1839 and he was he convinced Horace
Cutler who was a shoe hue manufacturer
to come in with him that this good year
was very good at convincing people that
fame and fortune was right around the
corner and I don't think he was lying I
think he believed that his whole life
and he convinced Horace Cutler to invest
to become a partner with him well Horace
Cutler's after a time said where's the
payoff and Goodyear kept with his
experimenting and and trying different
configurations of his oven and and and
the item the shoes would come out
blistered and so forth and and Cutler
after awhile became fed up and that was
when he went
my villain in the story came it came in
contact with Horace Cutler and convinced
Horace Cutler to come down to New Jersey
where where Horace day lived and
essentially tell him the secrets that he
learned from his close association with
Goodyear and in the course of a couple
of days Cutler basically spilled these
secrets which had taken Goodyear years
to develop what what happened what a
horse they do with that information
Horace day took that information and
tried to reproduce vulcanization and he
had difficulty doing it and it drove him
crazy as I say it's a delicate process
and even if you know how to even if you
have the basic formula it takes a while
to get the exact measurements and the
heat and so forth so des had difficulty
reproducing it he then went traveled to
Springfield and tried to wheedle his way
into the into Goodyear's mill and wasn't
able to get in and then after that he
sort of made a career out of once the
process became better and better known
and and perfected he made a career out
of ripping Goodyear off it at every turn
so back to the trial what year was the
trial and why did Daniel Webster get
involved in it the trial was in 1852 and
Daniel Webster became involved with it
basically because he needed the money he
first declined as I said he didn't need
the publicity of being involved in this
case was he you say he was the Secretary
of State at that point yes did he take
this case on as the Secretary of State
yes yes I think that was not unheard of
at the time to to do private it wasn't
the the the way I don't think it
obviously wouldn't happen today but I
think in what was the venue it was in
federal court in and the case was heard
in in Trenton New Jersey and who is the
fella choked
Rufus Choate was Daniel Webster's
opponent and he's a very interesting
character he's sort of similar to to
Webster a younger version he was maybe
15 years younger than Daniel Webster
both
graduates of Dartmouth both brilliant
lawyers
chote somewhat less famous than then
Webster less of a sort of mythical
figure but he had been senator and
Congressman and was was known as one of
the most skilled trial lawyers in
America and he represented him he
represented Horace day and in fact
Choate had you know the most celebrated
one of the most celebrated murder trials
of the 19th century he had represented a
fellow from from Weymouth Massachusetts
who had killed his lover and and choked
put forth a sleepwalking defense which
gave him quite a bit of notoriety and he
became known as the wizard of the law
because the the after the fellow was
acquitted and that the case was about
what between Horace day and Charles
Goodyear and who brought the case it was
a good good year and the good year she
was so shi'ites who were his licensees
because by this time good your had the
US Patent and they brought this case
against Horace day for repeat repeated
infringement turning out rubber goods
when he did not hold the license to do
that and he'd been doing it and and
patent and French an infringement was
rampant and I think that not just by
Horace day but by others but I think
they wanted to make an example of Horace
day and Horace day was a very combative
individual he fought numerous legal
battles not just against Goodyear but
all of his life against any number of
people and and and and he was a
combative soul and and so he didn't back
down and it all culminated in this in
his great trial and before the trial
lawyers for both sides took took
depositions from from from people and
and and Horace day found he dragged up
these individuals several individuals
who claimed that they in fact had
invented vulcanization Horace day
claimed that he had invented
vulcanization even though Horace Cutler
not notwithstanding so he was a prettty
who won the trial Goodyear won
resounding Lee it's not clear
how much money good year or the
associates or the associates ever got
out of out of Horace day but the
judgment came back resoundingly in
Goodyear's favor and it was it was
Daniel Webster's final court battle and
he and he won and and the decision
actually came down shortly before
Webster died 1860 he dies Charles
Goodyear 1861 the Civil War begins was
there any impact on what he had invented
on our either the Union side of the
Confederate side in the Civil yes
soldiers went off to to battle with they
with rubber tents rubber ponchos rubber
canteens and so forth it was it was
already becoming a major commodity the
the the benefits of vulcanization were
already apparent and so it was it was
widely used and then of course by the
20th century rubber along with oil and
food and a few other things it becomes
the thing that armies move and live or
die on and that's why it is a huge role
in the military and that that's why as I
said earlier when the Japanese by the
20th century all of virtually all of the
rubber plantations were in the Far East
and when the Japanese blockaded the
rubber plantations it was very serious
for the Allies and interestingly there
had been predictions that it would take
decades to come up with a with a usable
synthetic rubber and the United States
responded then with the period of a very
short period of a couple of years had
come up with synthetic rubber and that
was the birth of the synthetic rubber
during the 1940s you say then in 1853
that Charles Goodyear wrote a book
called gum elastic and it's varieties
with a detailed account of its
application and uses and of the
discovery of vulcanization that's all
one title yes and that was 1853 and that
only they only printed 12 copies of the
only yeah only a very few copies were
printed it was it was just
quintessential Charles Goodyear it a
huge effort very impressive but he never
entirely finished it if you get a copy
of the book you see where there are
words missing there are places that he
obviously intended to put in a paragraph
there are just actually actually blanks
on the page where there's a word missing
how big a book was it was two volumes
about total about 600 pages and you read
yes and it goes on and on and on about
most of it is his predictions for what
he thinks various uses of rubber might
be and it's just incredible the the
variety in fact the its interestingly
the the inflatable tire as I say is one
of the few things that he didn't didn't
predict but there's also a certain
element of memoir to it and he tells the
story of his of his quest to come up
with vulcanization but unfortunately
there there are some details and some
but it's it's sort of it's very vague on
lots of the things you'd like to know
more about so if you vulcanized rubber
today you start with latex well it's in
those rubber still starts which starts
with the latex and then it gets smoked
and turned into this hard raw rubber
from from latex into into rubber and
then from there it has to be broken down
and mixed mixed with it's mixed with
sulfur and then it is shaped into
whatever products going to be and then
it is subjected to heat and it emerges
vulcanized interestingly the term rubber
comes from from in the 18th century one
of the first practical uses well before
vulcanization was that it was found to
be useful for erasing pencil marks it's
for rubbing them out and that's where
the term rubber comes from you started
in this business where as a writer I was
a newspaper reporter out of college for
the Chattanooga Times where was college
first at Harvard and I my first job was
in Tennessee the Chattanooga Times and
then a tall MoMA in New York Times
well it's owned by the same but it's the
same family and there's still a deep
family association my publisher at the
time Ruth Homburg was a member of that
of the family and then after that I
wrote for the Richmond times-dispatch in
Virginia and was a feature writer and
then and then a business reporter and
then when I was coming out with blue
fairways they the book we talked about
earlier I left that to do freelance
writing full-time something I had always
told myself I would never do where did
you what year did you graduate from
Harvard in 1983 what'd you study English
and so how many years were you're in
newspaper reporter I was a newspaper
reporter for about let's see 80 about 15
years and why did you move to Trumbull
Connecticut my family I grew up outside
of Boston and my parents are still in
the Boston area my in-laws are in
Norwalk Connecticut which is down the
road from Trumbull and we just got tired
of two daughters two young daughters and
we just got tired of doing i-95 we loved
Richmond but it was time to get back
close to family and then I find it very
exciting to be near New York City it
says again and they information the back
on you that you write for Esquire
double-take what's that double take is a
literary of Arts cultural magazine it's
a wonderful magazine Reader's Digest 64
what's that 64 is a magazine
unfortunately it just went out of out of
business after I put the the reference
in there but it was a wonderful magazine
that was started in Richmond Virginia
sort of an arts and cultural magazine
very high quality production in it and
it covered Virginia and they were just
very kind to me when I started out in
freelance writing and gave me a lot of
magazine work and I and I want to
acknowledge them all right what is it
what's the origin I think I may have the
secret when you say with the Harvard
what the origin of the Robert Coles
Pulitzer prize-winning author of
children of crisis endorsing this book
well Robert Coles was a professor of
mine at Harvard and he I got to know him
a bit
I had actually written an essay you it
took a course I think it was called the
literature of social reflection and it
was a just a legendary course and but
several hundred students and and Cole
is sort of a legendary figure there and
I wrote an essay for his class never
thinking I would meet him but I was
doing some writing for the newspaper and
I published this essay in the newspaper
and they got a very nice personal
message from him a personal note which
was really a wonderful thing and have
been friends with him ever since then a
fellow named Dean King who was the
author of Patrick O'Brien alive says
Charles slack has plucked a gem from
American history how do you know Dean
Cain I know Dean King he is a writer who
lives in Richmond he formerly lived in
in New York City and I got to know him
when he was editing magazines in New
York he was from Richmond and I wrote a
couple of short articles about him for
the Richmond times-dispatch and we
became friendly and and I wound up doing
doing some work with him and he has
served made the transition into being a
full-time book writer and he moved back
to Virginia we've just become good
friends and he's in some ways been my
even though he's a couple of years
younger than I am we sort of become my
mentor in a lot of ways how would you
say today you make your living I make my
living as a freelance writer I do I
think when you do that you have to find
a formula that works for you and what
I've found is I do a lot of I do
magazine writing but when when it sort
of comes along but but the the my bread
and butter is I do a lot of business
writing for places like American Express
custom publishing and time incorporated
custom publishing and and so forth and
and that supplies a good chunk of income
and then I try to work on I have a book
going go back to some of these names in
the book Charles Goodyear we've talked
about Nathaniel Hayward a little bit
about Horace day Horace Cutler and now
Thomas Hancock who has his picture on
the front of this book we haven't spent
much time do you did you go try to find
out where he was from do you go to his
home well I he spent most of his life
living in London and I did
go to England one of the most satisfying
and rewarding parts of my research the
research took me all over the place in
the United States in the eastern United
States but one of the most rewarding
trips was was to England where I went to
principally two places the Science
Museum in London were where I came
across a box filled with records from
Thomas Hancock's company and the
subsequent companies that came out of
that and these were glass plates that
that hadn't been looked at for quite
some time but but I got it was down in
the basement looking for a machine that
came across all these records from
Hancock letters he'd written from his
records about his company which sort of
presented him he was in LA in a lot of
ways Goodyear's
precise opposite he was a excellent
businessman he was fastidious he was
well organized and Goodyear was was none
of those things and and a lot of that
came out in these documents that I found
in the basement of the London Science
Museum and then the other aspect of my
research in England was in Trowbridge
England near the home of Stephen Moulton
who's another character that we haven't
discussed but he was a friend of
Goodyear's who brought the samples over
that Hancock found and duplicated but
the the Moulton company records produced
that I found in Trowbridge England a
couple of boxes of handwritten Goodyear
letters and an letters about Goodyear
written by his business associates and
so forth it just gave a wealth of
insight and detail the the patent at the
time how how was the patent regulated in
this country or in England for that
matter and what is it regulated in how
were they who decided that somebody
would get a path well the US Patent
Office and and the as I say in patent
infringement was was rampant but you
you did have have recourse and that's
where the great India india-rubber case
came from yeah but go back to the fact
that he he didn't get the patent in
Great Britain right he did get that in
the United States how do you decides
that oh well well each in each country
has its own Patent Office and what
happened in England was Hancock had seen
these samples decided to
reverse-engineer Goodyear's process and
Goodyear was extremely foolish on
Goodyear's part to have sent these
samples over to England without
patenting them but he made this mistake
and and Hancock got a hold
reverse-engineered and and in England at
that time I'm not certain whether you
still can but you could apply for a
six-month sort of tentative patent which
would give you protection even though
you you hadn't got the formula down
exactly you could file for this and get
protection for six months so Hancock
filed for that even though we hadn't
fully unlocked the secrets and a matter
of a few weeks after that Goodyear filed
for a British patent but by that time
Hancock had already was already
protected than in the ensuing six months
Hancock was able to further protect the
process and came through with the patent
and in England the there are sort of two
two different approaches to patents in
England versus the United States and in
England the issue is not necessarily who
was the first to come up with the idea
it's who was the first to file for the
patent and in the United States
it's who came up with the idea first so
it's it's a it's it's a very significant
difference and I think Americans tend to
think yeah of course the credit should
be given to whoever came up with the
idea but there's a very logical reason
for the British British system as well
which is that that proving who came up
with an idea first can be a very
difficult process in the end how did
Charles Goodyear die at age 60 he died
on the way to visit his daughter who was
herself dying it's one of the tragic
parts of the Goodyear story he was
living in wash and then got news that
this daughter was was ill in Connecticut
and even though Goodyear himself was in
terrible shape he got on the boat and
and took this rough voyage too and God
as far as New York and his son-in-law
met him and and and gave him the news
that his daughter had died and I think
this broke whatever remaining spirit he
had and he essentially collapsed and was
taken to a New York hotel and died your
next book my next book I'm very excited
about it's it's it's about a woman named
Hedy Greene who was sort of the first
female tycoon of Wall Street she turned
a wailing inheritance of a couple of
million dollars into a fortune of a
hundred million dollars during the
Gilded Age at a time when when women
weren't allowed to vote and went served
toe to toe with the captains of the of
the Gilded Age and that book is going to
be published and I just have gotten an
agreement with echo press and that book
is going to be published in 2004 here's
the cover of the book titled noble
obsession about the discovery of a
rubber and on the cover is Thomas
Hancock and Charles Goodyear thank you
very much Charles Lacan thank you very
much I've enjoyed it